more than 90 potential coronavirus
vaccines are being developed around the
world former FDA Commissioner Scott
Gottlieb talked to Face the Nation
yesterday about when a vaccine could be
available well I think what we're gonna
have in the fall is hopefully multiple
manufacturers that have cleared early
stage safety trials and have millions of
doses that could be deployed in large
large scale studies inside cities and so
what you would do is deploy the vaccine
in the setting of an outbreak in a city
to both test whether it's safe and
effective so you're continuing to study
it and our David agus dr. David agus
joins us from Los Angeles this morning
David good morning you are involved in
helping design some of the clinical
development of X of a vaccine how
quickly do you think do you think this
could happen well listen I hope and pray
it's here by the end of the year data on
some of the vaccines are mature and that
they've taken vaccines that have been
used before and put in the section for
Cova 19 so they're skipping some of the
early safety studies because they know
it's safe the majority of the vaccine
and we'll see the results over the next
several months if those results are
positive it's certainly possible that we
have a vaccine in the fall what looks
most promising to you David well there
as you alluded to there you know close
to 100 vaccine candidates around the
globe and you know about a dozen
certainly have science behind them that
makes sense and you know there's the
Johnson and Johnson
there's the Oxford University there's
the moderna there's the Pfizer all of
those make scientific sense and can be
accelerated based on the data they
already have and so I'm encouraged but
the problem is is that you have to make
a very potent immune response for it to
work and we never know till it goes into
humans whether that immune response is
strong enough to provide immunity that's
the key question if we get something to
work with here David who would get this
vaccine first how would that work do you
think well they say Anthony Mason is
always first to get this and then
after Anthony will know it's health care
workers on the front line are key
obviously and then people at high risk
for complications and being admitted to
hospitals those are people with diabetes
obesity blood pressure issue and the
elderly those are the one that if they
get the virus are the ones who get very
sick and end up in being admitted to a
hospital so we need people to take care
of them that's the frontline workers as
well as the high-risk would be the first
are you expecting this would be seasonal
like the flu a seasonal vaccine or a
one-time shot well I think with
coronavirus what we're afraid of is that
the immune response will be good but not
great and so what that means is you're
going to need potentially yearly updates
of the vaccine to get your immune
response going when you get the flu
vaccine it classically lasts for four to
six months the immunity to influenza the
hope is with this vaccine it will last
till the next year and then another
vaccine is given to basically boost
immunity again it provides you another
year of protection but we're not going
to know until we see what happens until
we see the immune responses we should
have the first data coming out in June
so then we'll know a lot more as you
know David there are some people who
were very skeptical about vaccines what
would you say to them there are people
that are skeptical about side that seems
you know I think in this case we're
going to have to do a vaccine no matter
what you know the United States got you
know dramatically lowered its smoking
rates with secondhand smoke with the
argument it's not just affecting you but
it's affecting everyone around you if
you don't get a vaccine the problem is
there are a lot of people in the country
who cannot develop enough immunity even
with a vaccine and they may be some
elderly immune suppressed cancer
patients and others and so we all have
to do it to protect each other this it
has to be a communal event in order to
get hurt immunity so our country is
protected this is going to be everyone
stepping up to be part of the solution
and so I hope and pray that there aren't
Lords pockets of the country that don't
get vaccinated yeah alright dr. David
agus thank you David we're all rooting
for this by the end of the year
appreciate it